what scene did you have to do the most
takes on
i mean they're all about the same no we
uh we ended up reshooting a scene so
that's
that's probably the one four days and
four days i think so eight days see
that's another thing that has a negative
connotation reshoots but meanwhile it's
built into
into the schedule and it's there for a
purpose so i'm sure you're gonna name
drop the scene and then i'm gonna say
it's great
oh it's a great scene i'm on the pier
okay it just
it's beautiful here's why i love that
scene more than any other scene is
because
we got to reshoot it and i am so much
better in it and was so much more
comfortable
my i was because that was a real first
real scene i shot
and then we shot at the end and i was
even though i was pregnant and like
feeling
cold and a little ill
it was amazing i was like god thank
thank god we got to do this again i get
to find
more and make it better and make it make
more sense and be more
comfortable and all these amazing
uh and it was also really fun because it
was the last
thing that we got to do together i love
that introductory moment and you know
it's like the cliche
concept of a of a film is always like a
moving finish line or goal line too so i
can understand the
the draw to wanting to find to fine-tune
things
and get to revisit them and spend more
time on them oh so
worth it every minute it was
and i thought it was going to be cold
but no it was just
it was great give me warm fuzzies to
think about it